is there advice you can give to young
people today
about life
you
broke
many rules
all the rules
some rules should be broken
so if you look at somebody young today
in high school and college
thinking
how they can uh break the rules legally
and live a life that's uh something they
could be really proud of what would you
say
biggest lesson i've learned um
you you want your life
to be one where you're helping people
and not hurting people
and
that that really hit me the first time i
walked into quantico
you know that you see the uh the
brightest minds in the united states who
give up
a lot of money the opportunities a lot
of money because they believe in helping
people um where i spent a career just
hurting and harming individuals that's
that's a hell of a lesson and i'm glad
i'm there
but i would tell people out there you
know
it's fine to want money
it's fine to do that it's fine to test
systems
it's fine to circumvent the rules if
you're not breaking the law it's fine to
do all that i like doing that all right
but if you've got the mindset if you can
just adhere to the mindset of helping
people and not hurting people
i think you'll be all right at the end
of the day
you